hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the continuation of
Eve I did not know that there was more
but here we are again I didn't I thought
I thought the series was gonna end a
while ago but apparently there's plenty
of stuff to be done May I'm a color okay
this one's easy just don't touch it oh
god I am awful oh it doe worst I am da
worst
I cannot even comprehend how to even be
- dingus dish jinkx are you know what
going Gary doesn't even care this time
he's like oh you want to go you know you
want to go you don't want to go what's
good we'll go for Gary cuz being back
here when that painting comes alive
sure would be bad news Oh
the only reason this is hard it's cuz
controls but floaty
oh boy I would help many more help well
I only have one I only have one yeah
there we go
got it got it nailed it all by birdy did
you do all this Bernie did you do all
this
Bernie come on you're done goofed real
hard this diamond these part blank and
experiment in white space sorry but this
comes off as a lack of effort for me
well Gary mr. premiere artist hey IVA
could we rest a bit sure all that
running around my legs mo tired
exhausted you should take a rest soon -
I've been told to talk to you as much as
possible don't leave the room without
him and he's asleep
I would never relieve this room ever
without you ever oh my Oh wha huh huh
okay runnin more stuff down apparently
what's going on what happened
Oh the class fell down I was looking
down okay hang on hang on I'm writing it
on my victory page in lights 61850 of
person Oh
oh it's the paintings in the other room
with the many eyes I know what it is
see Hey all right then there's got to be
more middle fades glance 182 all green
painting two eyes green do i hey man how
much did this guy paint geez okay smile
sixty two one two one-eyed woman
originally drawn with two somewhat
famous stolen Museum returned the next
day wait what does it is this wait no I
miss will be and you're repainting okay
that doesn't help at all
that doesn't help at all fine whatever I
got it
entering the secret room read how to
enter well huh read the writing on the
back of the east bookcase okay you mean
down here no no Ystad would be over here
look at the gap behind the long
bookshelf
now look at the canvas
do I wanna there's a little title on the
lower right of the painting you don't
know this word Gary wake up I need you
to know this word for me fine Gary you
go sleep Cubism oh hey there
EG seeds it up a little bit hey old
newspaper central jar just ahead of
their time who was Weiss gear Tara dear
Tina Guatemala Lara I thought there was
gonna be something there close your eyes
and count to three then it should be
ready okay oh this is what I'm going to
hang myself with oh no oh I done goofed
xxx crows five and five xxx
oh I done goofed oh I don't do oh I
don't you okay how many crows one crow -
crow three crow that is the same crow
three crows yes three crows and five
what's one snake - snake reasoning what
we know is they were one Apple who Apple
riyal horrible damn it that is the same
at one fish two fish a roll baby
three fish for fish one more baby
five fish booyah bye fish five fish
that's what it is
four crows or three crows my fish yay oh
god I hope this is right yeah I'm good
at counting the five yeah oh yay hey I
won on the on the psycho game can I go
home now
um excuse me
oh no no what are you talking about what
why why would you do that to me you son
of a [ __ ]
are you joking me what the hell was that
you have got to be
I am very upset right now okay I'm white
perturbed I I McKenna Oh
Oh I'm not I'm not not okay not okay you
know what I'm not okay I'm not okay I'm
not okay with that why was that a thing
why what the hell happened why did I
game over
Oh lower right wall never should you go
to the upper left wall god dammit you
have got to be [ __ ] me um very upset
I am very my jimmies are so busy you
know what I don't even want to discuss
it I don't want to talk about it I don't
want to talk about it cuz that was dumb
that was dumb oh dude
Eber where did you go
you worried me so much I'm sorry no I
should be I shouldn't have yelled I
panic when you weren't there I shouldn't
have fallen asleep like that sorry Eve
you're not hurt are you or I just died
geez good let's get going
alright that was fun for glad we did
that
hello mr. chirpy birdy hahahaha you know
what it's okay I was that guy again
hey let me before I get in there earth
of the camper NICUs revolution
revolution
look down is this AG where Tina please
is this just beyond the realm of died
god no oh god don't know no oh boy I am
falling am i dead oh good I'm not even
up please my Rose needs some help
are you okay are you in why of course
you're in pain but woo what about Gary
well it hurts here and there I should be
able to walk it off we should certainly
watch our back from now on no joke
Wow god dammit what did that do his
heavenly bodies weren't there
what Oh weren't where
want me treasure yes
Oh God
how am I supposed to do this you mean
what's having this bunny worth there
I've won Dan don't kill me don't kill me
oh okay there we go oh thank goodness
oh thank goodness gracious oh thank
goodness
I thought I would oh god damn it this is
hole doing here Oh endless corridor this
should be fun wait what
no Derby bird little jimmy bird oh look
at the little chirpy bird walking out of
pattern wait nope
kirby bird you're going up Derby Burdick
I didn't
chirpy bird chirping bird eye is this
great oh I did it
oh look at it look at it alone every
bird
oh that's so adorable I don't hope I
don't need to go back this okay there we
go okay okay that's good this douche bag
here this [ __ ] okay so what I need to
do is I need to find what's the lest
you'll bodies aren't there does that
even mean what does that mean I don't
know what it's in talking in reference
to because there was there painting
around here that I need to see nothing's
still sleeping
god I wish you had water I hate running
around with one chance
oh there's got to be a way to solve this
painting is there some is there one of
these that's different than the others
that would be my first assumption pretty
pretty easy to tell because they're all
same pixel style nothing immediately
jumps out to me
oh hi the hell oh wow I did it how did I
do that did I get it I'm gonna be
perfectly honest guys I don't even know
why I picked that one
I really don't I'm dead serious guys I
don't know why I picked that one hahaha
that was either the luckiest luck of
luck history or I'm amazing and I'm
totally awesome I'm gonna go with that
one cuz I'm so great I'm good oh I am
good I am the best okay so there was
nothing actually up here come down woo
you owe the celestial bodies up there
I need to keep throwing myself down a
hole okay I wasn't really looking I saw
red red giant and I need to get this
right or I'm going to die that is for
damn sure
this may take me some time and just cuz
you guys can pause the video see maybe I
can and if I look down
yeah there were decorations hang on let
me look come on
memorize okay blue okay I think I got it
the orange star was not there
the orange e-1 it was deviling him there
that great thing was there born that one
was not there who was the other it was
the redder one that one was there not
only on that side I don't remember
seeing that green guy but let me take
another look I can't risk you to mess
this up no I mean no I mean I mean no no
Hey looking for a green does anyone see
a green no green honey I know I didn't
see a green up there booyakasha bear you
kiss chippy okay get it yep solved you
smart fine you have me treasure thank
you
got the painting all right I only need
one more know where I'm gonna get it but
I only need one more so what do I do
about that last one link plate Wow
where was the last one maybe in here
wait was there always a dent in that
yeah I wasn't dented before hey hey you
dick
don't be dented why are you dented is
there a painting in you why you dented
wait no come on don't something about it
you you see the problem ergo you need to
solve the problem
ah come on I never mind you know what
fine
I've been bottom right up and bottom
left I've been left top left top right
then everywhere except for why is this
suddenly dented that was not dented
before tell me your secrets I would love
to know them any day now any day now ah
ah yeah I got I got the secret from you
don't know how though no I don't I don't
think there would be any other from here
really don't know there wouldn't be
there's gotta be something to this
something that I'm not immediately see
maybe this guy has something and I need
to do something about that what happens
if I go back what about this lady hey
lady lady lady lady lady no fine drown
in the abyss well that's a little morbid
don't you think captain here I did this
thing got it from there was there any
other part down here coz it was kind of
strange that I closed the book on him
and and then there's a book on him then
didn't do nothing about it what about
this [ __ ] here insomnia coughing why
you be sleeping why you so tired man
something something something here
gotta be some here look up arrow um had
to be a reason that I could close this a
qua book don't know I don't know I don't
know peep what does that mean we mean
peep dammit hmm oh god are you kidding
me that one oh I forgot I didn't get
that one
oh I'm such an ass I'm such a dick this
really the man himself I heard where
Tina didn't leave any self-portraits oh
Jesus oh there we go
hot damn into queer tane ahem Oh what's
up I haven't saved Kenai
they say final stage I haven't saved a
little beer ah crap
do you mean
you
Oh
Oh what about this what do we do about
this what am I supposed to do why would
you have an option to not touch it oh I
see oh okay I get it it would be a bad
idea to sleep on that wouldn't it just
in my opinion oh why am i back there
wait a minute some a right
so
some a right
from now right
I just want to save everybody right oh
it's gone god damn it
okay this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
be a man
I'm always flipping our bed I'm or
slippers leaving that bad
hello leaving their bed if leavin being
so macho about sleeping in the bed
animal even have bird here you heard me
poopy doopy doopy doopy got that get it
over there get it over there it's timely
you me faced off guerre Tina come here
you [ __ ]
why are you so psycho bonkers crazy you
think the whole world would like know
that yeah go sleepy but I'm gonna get
the key first one moon do okay Keith mmm
damn sleeping you leap whitey but this
piece give me a bad feeling I think we
should stay away oh well what the hell
am I supposed to do i well alright then
suck on that [ __ ]
there's your bedside table what AVL is
supposed to go over here and look at
this
maybe Oh supposed to go here look at the
coffin man
what am I supposed to do I'm so confused
gonna go back
Oh No I can't do it okay
obviously I gotta go forward I that's
just what I gotta do I guess so confused
I'm so confused
I what what I don't I don't I guess I'm
done baby
Hey oh yeah that led back to the yeah
why do I have a black key why do I have
a black key I am so confused
hi I'm so you
well here's back here this is where
supposedly the game ends right right
well ah there's absolutely nothing I can
look at besides that so I guess this is
it
tick yeah Beck that's sack fat back
I don't know I don't know
yes yeah yeah Gary flam swing swamp look
the frame might be our chance unwrapped
alright you got it buddy how friend i'ma
come on my way good a bubala
you'll never be my mama
I'll pull you grab Gary's hand yep
why do I have the black key why do I
have the black
can't remember what I was doing Lidda
world I go over here then the museum
music plays then I go over here and then
I can go over here write down my life
story in front of this guy go over here
go down this boy hawked Gras hmm what is
it little lady what are you looking at
hmm it's a rose sculpture when I look at
this sculpture I feel sorrowful I wonder
why trouble you EEB you know my name
who's II wait that's your name your
name's really Eve that's the strangest
thing I mean I don't know you at all
this time it came out how odd but
actually if we perhaps met somewhere
before my look at me asking you such
strange things
never mind what I said well goodbye no
no maybe
hmm this a hand kerchief ah this is
yours my word it's true Eve your name's
right on it why is it in my pocket
plus there's blood on it Oh
I was
I was wounded on the hand and a girl
her handkerchief
yes sandwich if were given to me as gift
a gift from EEB ebuy remember now we
were together back there how could I
forgotten it was so important we stuck
together through that Bazaar gallery
chased by strange statues and Mary too
right Eve do you remember I remember oh
thank goodness it's hard to believe even
now but it must have happened right if
we got back face Lee we did it basically
haha it's so much more to talk about but
I've got to get going
I II did all right if I keep this
handkerchief a while longer I wouldn't
do to return it as it is I'll have to
make clean and then give it back okay
cuz we will see each other again okay no
don't I have a black key
I'm gonna
as dumb now right here something not
right here
ladies and gentlemen something is not
right
this is not what he was supposed to be I
was promised
something to do with a black pea and yet
I have nothing
dami biz short Oh Gary is freakishly
tall
why did I help Blackie
why did I get a blank Hey
oh don't tell me I have to play through
the game again because I will have you
in but
Hey
next time on Eva goodbye
what I'm gonna find out what the hell
this is all about you just lady IBAs see
daughter adventures I've got him yeah
yeah what all I see
always do then do I need game over
cuz it is is the game
how cool is it ah
so call the blank a blank plate why is
it so silent in here blank plate don't
do that to me why I want to know why why
was it styling in there you know I'm
still confused
you
so is this nothing but a gallery of all
the things and ins and outs of what can
and cannot be reality
I guess it's literally just all of the
oh maybe I didn't look at all the
paintings and some of them aren't walls
or I think I looked at everything
oh cool look at this look at this oh yes
- look at all this you know come I guess
I didn't look at some paintings maybe
ruin of the heart huh interesting
well there sure is a lot of stuff here
nasty
hey you freaky you all freaky you freaky
D me know like you damn there was a lot
more stuff in this game than I thought
oh very very cool I'm still wondering
why that was a blank slate place blank
plate deal man I did speed through this
playthrough to try to get to the ugh
when I was cuz I originally got to here
just because I was going for the ending
ending oh look it's the little and it's
the little Ian yeah your paintings real
cool
oh hello mr. kitty the live paintings
what is this oh that's a doll oh oh my
still sinister fish tongue EGH I'm the
naked lady all the good stuff that you
needed art well the good art stuff I
didn't look at a lot of things I am
sorry I was in a rush to get back to
make Gary fall in love with me well that
would be weird cuz he was like 10 years
old or something
no not fall in love but hey look it's
Gary
hey there was aa white ant in the
gallery white ants don't usually candy
but well they don't usually speak either
thanks Gary for your insightful in today
you're just the wonder of everything in
the world yeah believe I'm have the
honor of you
hello mother mother the other favorite
piece EEB where's father I guess this is
it huh very interesting I guess that's
it unless there's some other secret here
leave the true grant aina exhibit unless
there's something else I need to see
bada bing bada boom
there you have it oh wait no this is
just a story the game again
nah oh go away go away go away oh why is
it starting again would you do that no
nope
there we go okay went into the main menu
boom done that was the end of Eve I have
found everything I did everything kept
the bad endings I didn't do that but
don't expect me to do those I did
everything I loved this game it was
fantastic I think this was a
fantastically made game you know
obviously graphic wise these things
don't go I say this every time you grab
this you know if you if you just account
did the graphics not gonna be great
but approach it as it's stylized for
what it is this game was great it was an
adventure great story
still don't know what was up with guerre
Tina being able to make all his
paintings all wacky duty but still had a
lot of fun it was awesome I loved it so
thank you all so much for watching I
sincerely enjoyed this if you got
another RPG or game that you want me to
play I will happily do it if it's a good
so thanks again everybody for watching
thanks everyone I always appreciate when
people stick through the long let's
plays like this and I really appreciate
you making it to the end now so thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye